foreign
let's go to Linda in Kansas City what's
up Linda
Hi how are you I'm so good how are you
I'm doing fine thanks I'm I'm an honor
to talk to you sir thanks for taking my
call I am super I want to talk to you
and
for those of you who don't know who you
wouldn't know
um I hung up on Linda I had a screwy
intro we have to edit out that you'll
never hear but Linda you heard it also
I'm glad you you're sticking around with
us well thanks I'm gonna figure out how
this thing works at some point good
grief all right so what's up
um okay so I have a question
um I've done a lot of research I just
kind of need an answer is sexting
cheating that's kind of my big question
and so although
I I
listen listen
you've you heard the show before have
you been I mean Have you listened to
show before
yeah a lot okay
so you'll understand what I say a lot
it's rare that somebody just walks up
and puts a ball right on the T for me or
or just throws an underhand pitch and so
on behalf of all of humanity and
especially me thank you thank you so
explain explain this explain your
question a little bit more
that's what I've been married for seven
years
oh good God almighty okay so you live in
a living under yeah pretty much
um and a couple of months ago I was on
my husband's phone working for an email
confirmation to repeat Netflix or
audible or something like that and the
first text message that I saw was good
morning baby I'm like that's a little
weird so I looked a little bit in his
form a little bit more and I saw some
flirty pictures and some sorority texts
and still I thought that's a little
weird so I checked Snapchat and some
other social media and there were naked
pictures of nine other women
still I thought that's really weird
that's not normal right so I brought it
up into our counseling session because
we are in therapy and he admitted to
sexting three women over the last two
years
I was you know absolutely devastated and
when I tried to talk to him outside of
counseling he got really upset and
really offended that I used the word
Affair and he says he didn't cheat
because there was no actually he had
never had actually had sex with anyone
else uh but he has hung out with several
of them in person before and after the
sexting cheated in a group setting and
and one-on-one with a couple of them so
is is sexting cheating is this is it
worse when the women aren't strangers
um are these Affairs or am I just
blowing us all out of proportion I think
you're crazy Linda I don't think you
have anything to worry about
like before I answer this are are you
I'm asking this I have I'm I have a
smile on my face but I'm not I'm not
being a jerk okay okay
like ask yourself this question pretend
that one of your girlfriends calls you
and was like hey I need to go get coffee
and she had snuck she had taken her
husband's phone
and it was full of these conversations
with other women naked photos of other
women
um confirmation that he was hanging out
with them
what would your answer to Herbie
Alex absolutely
one one
percent this is cheating
no if ifs and this I mean this is gas
like I mean the gaslights are burning so
bright here because you are the one
walking around feeling like you're crazy
but then I think like who am I to say
who he can and can't text who am I to
say who he can't hear his wife
wife
and when I married my wife
I invited her in to have a say into my
life forever
that's what marriage is
now even if we've been in survival mode
for the last five years with babies and
toddlers And I'm not as I'm not as
pretty as or as thin as I used to be is
it okay for him to get visual
stimulation from Sexting in strip clubs
or again is that
still cheating Linda what happened with
you
why do you think so little of yourself
it's been a rough couple of years yeah
but I mean
where where is this coming from
you're the mother of four incredible
kids
this is
I mean I I don't even I I I you listen
to show I'm speechless I don't have
words
this isn't about well I don't look how I
used to you have four children under six
and under this is this is the moment
that a husband steps up and rallies
around his wife and and through the The
Crucible through the uh challenge of
having four little ones you become more
unified than ever and you got to figure
out how to do a completely new life
because life before four kids was
chaotic and y'all could just have sex
whenever and you could leave clothes all
over the house and your bras hanging
from a ceiling fan and your husband
doesn't know his pants or that was that
life and it was awesome
and now you got a bunch of children
and you could still have that life but
you got to plan it right and it's got to
be it's just a totally different way of
being
this isn't for you to be like well that
was fun for that 18 months before we
started having kids and now I'm just
ugly and not worth being loved and I
should high-five him as he heads out to
hook up with these women and by the way
a thousand percent he's lying to you of
course he's hooked up with them
that's insane it's Madness
okay yes
I mean I I I mean I can't imagine a
scenario
and there's some anonymity if you will
to strip clubs or some anonymity to
pornography that's a whole other
conversation okay
this is people he's in relationship with
he hangs out with them he has dates with
them when a when someone goes out
one-on-one with somebody that they've
exchanged naked photos with that's
called the date
okay he's actively dating women that's
not you
and I like
I don't say I'm defending him but it
sounds like you've given him permission
well when you put it like that kind of
yeah but he has he said he's he's cut
off all contact with three of the nine
and so
I mean Linda Linda Linda listen
you are getting the world you're
allowing
if you want a husband
who
is about integrity and Fidelity then
that's the world
that um
I wish I had a better word for it that's
the world that's the world you demand
that's the world you say I'm worth
and if you want a husband that's got
nine girlfriends on the side
then knock your lights out
but you might as well go ahead and file
for divorce now just call it
because you're going to torture yourself
at the altar of I'm not pretty enough or
I'm not good enough or I used to be but
now I'm not
and you're worth so much more than that
and by the way
your kids are watching this they're
absorbing this this is what marriage and
love looks like this is what commitment
and I'll be with you till the end of
time through sickness and health they're
absorbing this oh sweet when she gets
when she gains weight
you go get some on the side
when you gain weight you have to let
them go because you're no longer Worthy
of integrity and fidelity
go ahead I'm sorry I cut you off go
ahead
is it reasonable for me to expect to
talk about this outside of our weekly
therapy sessions
I mean the fact that you're asking this
question tells me
this relationship's so over
yes you can talk about this anytime
for it in any place in I mean
I like why would you ask that question
are you safe is he abusive
no he just has like a lot of anxiety
when he talks about it
all anxiety is as an alarm
and of course the alarms are going off
because he's caught he's busted and he's
got a pretty sweet deal right now he's
got a live-in nanny for his four kids
and he's got nine girlfriends on the
side
and so anytime that little world gets
threatened of course his anxiety alarms
are going to go off
but that I can't talk about it it makes
me anxious shut up get over yourself
that's bullcrap and I've got anxiety I'm
clinically diagnosed so I can say it
it's bullcrap
foreign
you up like a Christmas tree with the
gaslights my sister
I
I don't think you are able to and I
don't it's I understand okay
I don't think you are in a place
where you can wrap your head around the
reality of your of your marriage and the
situation you find yourself
and I don't know who told you
that you had so little value
but they lied to you and they were wrong
you are worth so much more and by the
way I'd be saying this if he was sitting
on the phone I'd be saying this if he
was sitting right here at this desk
the way he's treating you is disgusting
it's unbelievable
and I'm sorry
when I say it do you do you believe it
or do you think I'm crazy
and it makes I
makes me feel a lot better than I'm not
going crazy
yeah
I think someone said that to me in a
while what are you gonna do what does
your counselor say for God's sakes
um we haven't really addressed if it's
cheating or not cheating quite yet
Hey listen you need to find a new
therapist
and I'm I I'm saying that directly and I
I would say that to the therapist who's
sitting right here
it's cruel that's the old guard of
therapy is you just sit there and you
play referee while two people kind of
say their thing and it kind of comes out
and what all of the emergent literature
suggest is that's cruel because you
watch one person
drown somebody in a session
and the new the new way to do it my
buddy calls it wave three of therapy as
people were figuring out how human
beings work right which is really just a
laughable way of like we're finally
being
um wise
is you take sides you call it out
I'm gonna stop you right there sir
you're having a sexual relationship with
nine different people
and you're married to her
see what I'm saying I I'm sorry that
your counselor has just let this go on
that's nonsense
absolute nonsense
so sexing is a sexual relationship then
just unequivocally never for a second
doubt that as long as you live as much
as I'm sitting here wearing a black
shirt with buttons on it
sexting somebody is engaging in a sexual
relationship
period
there is no discussion there
is that new it can't be news to you
Linda
no it's not I just
as Rose colored glasses on and so I just
want to see like it's not really it's
not really cheating it's not really
because there's a lot online there's
four little kids on the line yes
and you are digging a hole in your
backyard and burying yourself in it
so that you don't have to face reality
that your husband sucks
Fair
yeah
fair I'm sorry man I'm I mean I'm with
I'm I'm heartbroken for you
I can't I can't wrap my head around how
it got here
me neither
I would recommend
with all of my being that you go see a
counselor on your own
foreign
because
you are entering into you would be
entering into marriage therapy it's such
a distorted power differential
you think so little of yourself
that it's
you have been told probably for most of
your life
that you have so little value
or your only value is in a few things
and then we had kids and so they're gone
for the time being and so la da da
and
it's it's gonna it's it's kind of like a
um uh extension cord trying to go into a
plug in the wall the plug in the wall is
so
messed up that we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to go to an electrician and
have them pull it out and help rewire
this thing
because you have to be able to look in
the mirror and say I'm a person worthy
of being loved
and I'm a person worthy of there's chaos
in my home and there's gonna be for a
while
how can we have romance romance and
sexual intimacy and fun and laughter and
flirtation all that how can we create
that world inside of the chaos of
diapers and clothes everywhere and
random socks and some kid just peeing
all over the place like how do we do
that inside of that and that is
what strong marriages do
is they see the challenge ahead and they
choose to enter into it they lock arms
even tighter
and there is chaos and bumps and bruises
along the way
because we keep remembering back to the
way it was that season's over
gotta build a new a new thing moving
forward
but my big my bigger concern here
is you just summon through your
husband's phone
with pictures of nine different women
he's meeting with and who are sending
him naked pictures and
who he's having dates with
and you think something's wrong with you
hear me say this
you're worth more than this
if I can do anything to help you along
the way I'll be here let me know